a dog towns medical clinic vet tech Jeff
Popovich prepares for a new arrival
Bruno is an aging child with troubling
symptoms disorientation and constant
drooling hi baby
where's your new dog town volunteer
nadine good ro drove him here from a
shelter in LA nearly 500 miles away so
you picked him up April 23rd old and in
poor health he was moments away from
being euthanized nadine hopes dog town
can figure out what's wrong with bruno
and find him a loving home you ready big
guy
come on bruno as head bet tech jeff is
the first staffer most dogs meet when
they arrive at dog town it's his job to
do an overall medical assessment so what
we're gonna do now is a quick exam basic
things that we can do so that we have a
better picture to paint for one of the
vets that will look at him all right
well let's look at your grill kid can we
open up Thanks we do have a different
perspective on dogs here than most
people Bruno is typical of that most
people will say there's a dog knocking
on death's door
we don't see it that way Bruno's a dog
that with a little TLC he can be bounced
around Jeff moves Bruno to his new
quarters at old friends one of 98 group
houses at dog town old friends is where
the senior dogs live at dog town usually
it's the dogs that are 8 years and older
Bruno joins about 40 other elderly dogs
who call this place home he's ready Jeff
hopes the other dogs will raise Bruno
spirits he's gonna finally get a hang
out with other dogs
so it should be a good day for him if he
ever gets in there
he likes to stop and sniff everything
along the way once Bruno gets healthy
again Jeff hopes the old child will
catch someone's eye I like seeing Bruno
around now that he's out there all it
takes is one person to come by and fall
in love with that guy and take him home
he loves sniffing
after working for years at dog town just
convinced that every dog can find a home
I haven't seen anything that says man
he's not adoptable person never met a
dog that's not adoptable either but
before Bruno can get adopted first dog
town was bacon well hey Bruno not sure
about his vision not sure about his
hearing he's got a head tilt to the left
all the time I need rules off the
website the easiest thing to tell from
Berlin when he first looked at him was
that this balance was off his head was
tilted to the side he didn't really even
have a full awareness searching for
signs of infection dr. Mike hopes that
Bruno's symptoms don't indicate
something worse
but Bruno's problem with balance
suggests something more serious you can
see how he stands now that often goes
along with some type of neurologic prom
most dogs when you place their feet and
weird directions either too wide or
cross them they should write them on
their own pretty quickly especially for
a dog that had been in a foster home for
a couple weeks to me that's a deeper
rooted brain disorder going on there's a
good boy dr. Mike must monitor Bruno
over time to determine the best course
of treatment Jeff hopes for the best
barring something like a brain tumor
even then you're just gonna monitor
quality of life and it's not that you
can get a dog to live for 10 years it's
that you can give him good years but
it's always quality over quantity and
bruno is a dog that definitely has the
potential to have a quality life but for
now Jeff's hopes for Bruno's adoption
are put on hold
over their years of Dogtown dr. Mike and
his wife Alyssa have fostered and
adopted many animals in need how do we
get so many animals it just happens
rescue foster foster rescue rescue hey
Bruno hey buddy how you doing
good boy look at you coming over to me
your guard whoops
sorry so little off-balance good boy
good boy all right we'll get you some
food here soon
Alisa and I had decided to try them at
home and kind of see how he did in a
home environment but after a few days in
their home Bruno's taking a turn for the
worse the first night he was very very
restless I was pacing vomited a few
times hey Bruno time for your dinner
anybody seen you up right here
all the whites bruno struggles to eat
and dr. mike grows more and more
concerned certainly a dog like Verena we
always worry that is this the right
thing for him or are we just keeping him
alive for the sake and keeping it alive
after a long night spent watching over
Bruno dog town veterinarian dr. Mike Dix
comes to terms with a difficult decision
last night we decided to euthanize
Bernal at about 11:30 Brunel developed
bloat a painful condition unrelated to
his brain disease that twist the stomach
and cuts off its blood supply this is
one of the saddest things you have to do
as a veterinarian but but at least Brno
is not suffering anymore nestled at the
edge of angels canyon angels rest as dog
town's pet cemetery today
Bruno joins thousands of other animals
who found their final home at this
sanctuary
Bruno's friends at dog town honor his
memory by leaving polished stones on his
grave
I feel good that Bruno got to spend some
time at home before he passed away
that's our goal with every dog even if
it was for only a short period of time
it's still nice to know that he was
loved and he was in a home I think that
we did make him comfortable for the
amount of time we had and that's all you
can ask for